right do you want to get your scooter
Sam who we won't identify could no
longer be cared for by his parents what
good hand-holding so his grandmother
Sandra stepped in one for you and one
for the Ducks please he was just 14
months old and came with symptoms of
trauma
shall I watch the scooter
Sandra's retirement plans suddenly took
a turn
so life very different it's very
different
um I'd planned for five years time to
retire I can't do that any longer
because I've spent most of my savings
now to bring him up as far as he has
with incurred expenses from nursery
school and his therapy it was just under
2 000 pounds a month there was no
support at all I found those first
couple of months if I'm honest
horrendous absolutely horrendous
a review Into the care system published
last year found kinship carers such as
grandparents and aunts were undervalued
and today the government is introducing
measures to support wider family
networks to keep children out of the
care system
with 45 million pounds earmarked for
early intervention for struggling
families the government will provide
training and support for kinship carers
and 25 million pounds is being invested
in recruiting and retaining Foster
carers
the lib Dems say it's not enough and
want to give kinship carers financial
support in line with that offered to
foster parents their leader Ed Davey was
himself raised in part by his
grandparents that's my
Nana and Granddad he lost his father
when he was four and his mother died of
cancer when he was 15. the pressure on
his grandparents losing their daughter
and raising him is something that stays
with him
and I wrote this essay for my assessed
English O level
and it was all about
this how it was coming home with
attention and knowing what my mother was
going through
and uh
my my teacher said he couldn't Market
because it was so Raw
this is that mother-daughter
relationship as well which is an I was
right in the middle of it yeah
um but it was you know they were both
wonderful lovely people well all three
of them my mother was special
uh it's just one of these things but
that's why kinship care is so important
because you don't have that with anyone
else yeah and uh I'm sure foster care is
an adoptee carers um
um a brilliant and wonderful
um but uh
the the not allowing kinship carers to
do what they want to do
is a serious mistake
there's a record number of children in
the care system and it's set to rise the
question is will this extra help for
children like Sam be enough to reverse
that Trend Jason Farrell Sky News
foreign